so today i'd like to introduce
the new instrument from luminex xmap
intelliflex
the presentation is entitled rich
history of enabling groundbreaking
breaking research
for those who are not familiar with
lubanek's x-men technology um it's
basically a beat based
essay where you can run on protein bases
capture sandwich
competitive ss and direct or indirect
psychological essays for for instance
identification of
proteins
also patient stratification is also
protein protein interaction
also what can be done with this beat
based technology is genomic applications
like snap essays mrna essays and nuclear
assets sequences
it's an open technology it means that
you can build your essay
yourself but there's also a large kit
content on the market luminex is a tech
company and actually the next speaker
will be
of one of our partners
showing some more
kit applications
so in short there are a number of better
benefits uh compared
with the traditional techniques um if
you look at multiplex technology as an
example i
took
some data from two papers published
last year and this year
as an example at 21 plex and 80 samples
basically if you look at
if you do that with
classical elisa you need around 42
plates
if you do it with a competitive essay
like a planetary you can do it in three
plates and if you do it with luminex
technology you can actually do it all in
one go in one plate
so if you then compare luminex
technology
versus singleplex obviously use less
sample less time and labor
less expenses because you only do one
place rather than 42.
if you build bigger panels you get more
data more insights in your research
and it's quite flexible
and also better reproducible compared
with elisa
hence you will improve your scientific
output
if you compare it with other planar
arrays the big benefit is basically if
the beat based essay that is a
suspension in liquid
so the fish
the physics and the kinetics are even
faster
and because it's beat base there's also
a high surge to volume ratio also
increasing the sensitivity of your
essays
so the luminex intelliflex is basically
the best year of 25
years of luminex xmap development it's
the fourth generation machine which is a
just came on market basically this month
so if you look back at the history of
the company in 1995 it was founded uh
first she was the lumix uh luminex
homework which was upgraded to the 200
store market
the number of years later the flagship
3d
came on market a year later the mecmix
which is now only as ifd on the market
and basically 10 years ago we launched
our new system which is called
intelliflex which is completely
renewed so
optics are improved
hardware is improved it contains a fully
integrated system
and this system is modular compared to
all other systems that means
that
it's easier also to handle in the field
it has a reduced footprint compared to
our
current portfolio the luminex 200 and
flexion 3d so basically it's two
megapixels in size
it has
modules like optics module fluidx model
and plate module and the pc is also
embedded with a machine
with a touch screen
that means that
also service in the field is way easier
if for whatever reason something will
break down it's just swapping a module
and not taking out single components
and also there's no additional computer
x to the side so basically what you see
this machine is what you put on your
bench it doesn't take any more space
the machine has multiple usb
ports also one on the side of the
touchscreen
and it has a
network connector on the back so you can
put it in your local network
so compared to
all other systems it is quite alike
with the only exception that we now also
have a one additional violet laser
so basically if you look at luminex
technology
normally the red laser you
uses to identify the beats so the red
laser hits the beats
and then the light is scattered to the
side and then you have three apds
basically looking at the three cores
inside the beat defining it which beat
it is between one and five on it
and then the double discriminator or the
red side scatter which is basically
defining it if it's a single beat or not
and if it's not a single beat it will
end up in an abort rate
the green laser will give the classical
signal most of the time it generates
from pe so that's the amount of target
which is bound to your beat which is
then
comes into the ordin signal
the rp1
and then
only in tableflex there's a new laser
which is divided laser
a 405 nanometer vitalizer which comes
into the blue pmt tube and that contains
the violet and the secondary porter
so
if you would look how a classical essay
with luminex xmap technology actually
works
you see it here so if you want to do in
this case a free first bound drug essay
you
go to your first beat with a specific
antibody which will code or capture your
free drug
or your free and your bound rock
basically together
and then you come back with a specific
antibody
only detecting the free drug
then the other bead containing the same
coding antibody you come back with the
other
classical
the bound target as a coating
and then you run these two as two assays
through luminex equipment
if you now would switch
to an intelliflex what you can actually
do is take
the two specific antibodies and actually
label one with the classical pe
and label one with a violet die
and then run it as a target from the
same
beat
hence you end up with a dual reporter
essay
and there are multiple violent dice on
the market
so why did luminex choose violet
um
here you can see the spectral overlines
and what you will see actually is that
we chose a four or five nanometer laser
which is in the visible spectrum so
there's no additional regulations just
for a classical laser
the wire dye has no spectral overlap of
any of the other the green and the red
laser already in the machine
and because it's a wire dye the
wavelength is very short and it so it is
a
an intense wavelength
that means that also there are intense
report dies available on market giving
good signals in the machine
and what i already stated there are
multiple dies on market making
reagents available
and then i will show you later on that
there's no energy transfer between the
violet and the pe
channel
so
there's more improved
within
the technology um
something what we call optical noise is
basically taken out of the machine
and to assess optical noise you can use
spherotech rainbow calibration particles
and what is basically is you have these
color stained
particles
which will give a fluorescence pattern
and and here you can see
on the upper
figure
basically that if you look at the
flexible 3d as you can see the the light
green is still distinguished and then
the the the darker green and the yellow
and the red those peaks are basically
moving in each other and this is due to
the optical noise from the electronics
within the machine
now the teleflex is designed 10 years
later and of course technology doesn't
stand still and here you can see it's
actually that the interflex the optical
noise is taken out of this machine and
those three last peaks are separated in
a good way meaning that the optical
noise is out
this means that also you can run high
sensitivity essays with the machine
with one exception
is that if you reagents do not allow
improved sensitivity you will also will
not get it out of the machine so the
hardware is now capable but it still
depends on the essay
there are also multiple
detection modes in the intelliflex
and i will show you some data later on
but basically it is fully backward
compatible with all previous essays and
it will also have compatible measuring
motors that means that if you are
already a luminex user and you have an
lx 200 or a mac page in your lab you can
actually choose that setting in the
intelliflex and if you would measure 10
000 mfi in your lx 200 sa you also will
measure 10 000 mfi in the intel flex if
you choose that setting
same encounter for fn3d and if you run
160 000 mfi on your fm3d you choose the
fn3d setting and intelliflex it will
also give you 160 000 mfi
and then there are two additional
settings basically the do report setting
showing that you can measure two signals
from one beat
and there's a additional high
sensitivity mode on the machine
where the pe laser is boosted from 15.5
milliwatt to 50 milliwatts meaning that
the intensity of the
laser is improved and that will also
give you
an extremely high
mfi that means that if you normally
would run like 15 000 mfi if you then
run it on a 15 milliwatt output that
will result in an mfi of several million
so basically
there you can actually give an
additional boost to your signal if your
essay will need that so that's an
additional
feature of the dual reporter machine
the intelliflex will come on market
has two
versions one is the basic model which is
the x-map intelliflex
so it will have a capacity like our
flexion with 3d
500 different beats
dynamic range 5.5 log slightly bigger
than the fm3d
and then a compatible 963 812 former
plate and already stated a pc and
monitor are fully integrated in the
machine
reading times around 20 minutes for 96
well played in 75 minutes for 380 well
former plate
as shown it's fully modular
um
and
also
on front there's a sliding over which
means that if you want to clean out your
probe or need to replace the probe it's
quite easy
and then
the
machine will also come as a feature
which is called the internal flex drse
which stands for do reporter side eject
what it actually means is that there's a
machine where the additional laser so
the vital laser is in
and
it will come with a feature that you
also can unload your plate or load your
plate to the side of the machine and not
on the front that means that the machine
is extremely automated friendly because
if you now now place your machine next
to a
robotic system it means you don't have
to place your your system in
in the deck and that will save you a lot
of deck space
so let's talk about backward
compatibility testing and some tool
reporter applications and then um the
next speaker will actually show a lot
more data not on the dual reporter but
on
the kits for ecology
but this is data i got from uh from the
actually the next speaker
which where they run some
um backward compatible essays and you
can see here they they run it on several
machines in this case the lumix 200 and
flex map and then they run it in several
settings on intelliflex whatever already
discussed like the lx walnut low pmt or
flexion 3d high pmt in purple
take home message of this one and this
this was actually from a 45 plex that if
you run biological samples in any
comparable mode in any luminex machine
you will actually will find the same
biological data
so if you buy a terminal kit you it
doesn't really matter if you run it
through the lx200 a flexible 3d or an
intelliflex you will get your same
balanced data
so
so do a reporter essay and i've just
picked as
essay in this case for cover not an
oncology type essay but this is just for
an example because we just have
some data on it as the machine is just
out for a month
so basically what you will do in this
case you will code a target on the on
the surface of the beat
then you incubate with your sample if
you do a syrological essay it's not only
idg
which is bound to your target it could
also be iga igm dne
you incubate with your sample you watch
it and then you come back and then then
you can come back with
your classical pe like in this case an
anti-igg
and a violet dye
an anti-iga or ig and anti-idm
and then you run through the intelliflex
where the red laser as stated will
detect the beats and then it goes to the
green lanes for the pe signal and the
population with a violent signal
now of course we want to see that
if you run either the pe signal or on
the divided signal that there's no
spillover in energy or light emitted
between those targets
so this was a proof concept essay where
and i'll just talk you through it in
figure a
there was only a pe antibody present in
the sample
and figure b is same sample there was
only
an igm super bright antibody
present
and then figure c is that it was done as
do reporter
what you basically see and let's take a
whole message of this slide that if you
do a deal reporter essay
that the curves are exactly overlining
if you run it either as a single or as a
dual reporter that means that these
signals are not interfering with each
other also in a biological essay
this is also from the covet kit from
luminex basically this was a study where
we looked in various individuals
which were
covered naive haven't seen the virus yet
and were vaccinated with beyond the
pfizer and it was a kinetic study
and then we looked at antibody responses
in in time now basically what you can
see after nine to ten days after the
first shot you see a massive production
in this case and ig and iga it also
encounters igm which is not depicted in
this figure
and then on day 24 there was a booster
given and again you can see that as an
antibody response spe and
and igepe and iga
the middle picture for those who are
doing covet research probably know it
but this is basically uh plotted n
versus rbd and where you can actually
see is that in blue
that's where biological samples
pre-covered so they haven't seen the
fires and you don't see any
antibody response to either n or rbd and
then here you can distinguish those who
had a natural infection which are also
n-positive which are in red
and those who only are vaccinated which
are in black there are n negative
now what we also did
we run a sample set of 180 biological
samples
and which we're on
we're using ige pe labels on
magpix lx200 and fn3d
and then what we next did is we took the
same antibody clone and then we run that
as a iga and the drawing file at 421 on
the intelliflex and here you can
actually see the correlations between
the targets which are
again
matching quite well showing that
the interior flex is compatible it is
backward compatible and it doesn't
really matter if you run either spe or
in the violet channel you will get the
same biological data
well
what kind of dyes are on the market and
this is just a few we tested in this
case for proteomic assays
so super bright on the market and
horizon brewer 5 and 421 is on the
market and the nice thing is that these
two
molecules are available as streptavidin
so if you are having a classical
antibody you can use these two markers
um
to do a dual reporter essay and then
the nice thing is there are tremendous
amount of directly pe labeled antibodies
so this gives you a free choice making a
dual reporter
what you also can see is election 405 is
quite dim as is dialite 405 it will also
test the horizon 450
but that's basically
out of the range of the measurements and
that you also can see it it only gives
you five percent of the peak m5 super
bright
alexa 405 is quite dim however very
useful for instance in nucleic acid
because
there it is turmeric stable so um it's
easier to use for uh molecular assays
rather than two for protein assays
now what kind of applications can you
think about it
you can do like phosphorylation so you
can do a total target phosphorylated or
target you can do protein protein inter
interaction as discussed antibody ice
type like igm iga or cluster class
switch between ig-1993
also neutralization essays
you can do free first bound rock
receptor ligand interactions
and also as treatment in oncology can
for instance do selection of bispecific
antibodies or fusion proteins to see if
your targets are on there
so basically the sky is the limit
so as a summary
i believe that the intel flex is
basically the best of 25 years of xmap
experiments
the machine has
a number of hardware upgrades especially
the reduction of the optical noise means
that the machine is capable to run on a
more sensitive way
side ejection might be very useful for
automated streets
if you get a dual reporter a 500 beat
set you can harvest actually a thousand
data points per target
and then as an additional feature you
have the high sensitive option on the pe
label
and then it measures a
bigger range than
our other equipment and of course then
the dual report capability
hence there's some other features the
software is renewed it's completely
different
it looks alike but it has different
backbones and they're more export for
versions it's very easy to use both the
hardware and software and for instance
also some upgrades like there's a
barcode scanner in the machine so you
don't have to type in or load anything
from cd it's just scanning a barcode and
then all your car column variables are
in
and as stated it is fully backward
compatible with our current portfolio
so
with that i'd like to conclude uh my
presentation and give in the word to the
next speaker
okay thank you so in the second part of
this webinar i would like to provide uh
insights into asset solutions and
applications based on the luminex
multi-analyte profiling technology to
support immune oncology research
so to further elucidate the interplay
of tumor cells and the tumor micro
environment and better understand the
mechanisms that underlie cancer also in
view of potential therapies
exploring all facets of the immune
system and immune checkpoint pathways is
key
so the figure on the left underlines the
complexity of the immune system
which is a network that involves a
multitude of cells and molecules
including also a large number of soluble
factors such as cytokines and chemokines
that shape local and systemic immune
responses which overall depend on the
critical balance between stimulatory and
inhibitory mediators
so there's a dual role of inflammation
also in the context of cancer that
involves several cytokines which are
other cancer promoting or rather support
anti-cancer responses together with
soluble receptors and ligands of t cells
and natural killer cells as summarized
in the figure on the right that
critical players in immuno-oncology
which rapidly evolves and emerges as a
research field focusing on innovative
therapeutic approaches that take
advantage of the ability and the an
individual's immune system to fight
cancer
so among uh the key research areas uh as
shown here uh in immune oncology
cancer vaccines have evolved a strategy
based on antigens and neoantigens that
are released by cancer cells upon cell
death to stimulate a strong immune
response besides the chimeric antigen
receptor t cell or car t cell therapy
that further expands the adoptive cell
therapy
relying on the transfer and re-infusion
of the subject t-cells after specific
genetic modification which finally
enables them to recognize and destroy
cancer cells and the immune checkpoint
inhibition is another approach that is
based on therapeutic antibodies
targeting immune checkpoint pathways as
a way to attack tumor cells
the immune checkpoint pathways are
critical in balancing immune responses
in order to protect tissues from damage
when the immune system is active but can
also be dysregulated by cancer cells
that use them as a mechanism to
ultimately evade immune surveillance
so as outlined here on this slide among
first immunotherapies to market were
targeted to blocking effects of
cytotoxic t lymphocyte antigen 4 ctla-4
and programmed cell death 1 pd-1
with several antibodies actually
approved as immunotherapeutic drugs
ctla-4 is a negative regulator of t-cell
activation and proliferation and the
combining uh to its ligand
plays a role also during priming of
these t cells
uh blockade of the ctla-4 receptor by
specific antibodies however can enhance
t-cell activation and thereby drive
anti-cancer immune responses
the immune checkpoint protein pd1 on the
other hand is a negative regulator of
apoptosis and by binding uh to its
ligand pdl1 that is expressed often by a
cancer cell it can mass cancer cells
from t cell recognition and finally also
results in attenuated immune responses
so since the discovery of cancer therapy
based on inhibition of negative immune
regulation
such as
via ctla-4 and pd-1
a lot of strategies and agents have been
developed to target these immune
checkpoint markers which are actually in
clinical trials and also used in in
combinatorial therapies and
investigation of immune checkpoint
pathways still continues in order to
identify new potential drug targets and
predictive biomarkers for checkpoint
immunotherapy that is not only important
to optimize
potential therapeutic benefits but also
to minimize possible side effects and
and guide combination therapies
so to support cancer biomarker discovery
and verification across these key immune
oncology research areas we actually
provide two different applications and
in vitrogen assays for highly multiplex
protein and gene expression studies on
one instrument platform so they are
compatible with any of the luminex
instruments as previously presented on
the one hand we have the hybridization
based quantity complex assays with
incorporated branch dna technology that
allow for accurate rna quantitation of
up to 80 targets per well
directly from a blood lysed or tissue
homogeneous sample without the need for
rna purification on the other hand
procartaplex immunoassays enable
scalable and reproducible protein
quantitation with the simultaneous
detection of actually up to 65 targets
in a single sample of plasma serum and
other bodily fluids that require only 25
to 50 microliter of sample volume in the
96 well format and even less in the 384
well format that is now also available
as a unique format of pre-dispensed
lyophilized beads on a plate next to a
liquid formulation with a beat pre mix
provided in a while
so most importantly these multiplex
assay platforms can also be customized
by selecting any rna transcript or by
choosing from our broad list of protein
targets for human mouse and other
species that cover chemokines cytokines
but also relevant biomarkers for the
immuno-oncology
research space and many other areas of
biology
so um to better understand also the
molecular basis that may underlie cancer
related immune responses the human
immune oncology checkpoint panel on the
quantity platform enables the
simultaneous measurement of 50
checkpoint modulators and immune cell
type markers as listed here in a 96 or
384 well format
besides the custom research panels can
also be designed incorporating
particular targets of interest and
allowing the relative gene expression
data to be obtained for these selected
targets
from the same sample
as shown here as an example in a
publication in the journal of
immunotherapy of cancer a custom
quantity plex panel was used for gene
expression profile analysis in the
pre-clinical discovery and development
of a novel monoclonal antibody that
binds to the pdl1 checkpoint ligands and
to evaluate the effects of this antibody
a high content molecular analysis were
performed on cell lysis from mixed
leukocyte reactions as depicted by the
volcano plot in the upper left as well
as on tumor tissues collected from
several xenograft mouse tumor models as
illustrated by the plot on the upper
right so analysis of in both models
revealed finally a prominent t cell
response upon addition of this blocking
antibody consistent with t cell
activation and also involvement of the
interferon gamma pathway
furthermore by comparing a single agent
treatment versus a combination of pdl1
and ctla for antibody treatment as shown
in the venn diagram below
gene expression changes indicative of
immune activation was observed for
single anti-pdl-1 treatment as well as
enhanced t cell activation in response
to single anti-ctl-4 treatment and
furthermore a combination resulted in
further upregulated th1 type responses
so overall these highlights how a
quantity implex assets can effectively
support the evaluation of potential
novel immunotherapies as demonstrated by
the ability of this antibody to
effectively block the the pdl one pd-1
axis to drive a more effective
anti-tumor t-cell immunity
on the brocardoplex platform in recent
years the main focus
of development activities was also on
immune oncology biomarkers for
investigating immune checkpoint pathways
functionality ineffective t cells and
natural killer cells so schematically
shown in the seven step process of this
cancer immunity cycle
in the figure on the left that
summarizes how the immune system combats
cancer cells initiated by the release of
cancer cell antigens upon cell death
followed by the optic and subsequent
presentation of cancer antigens t cell
selectivation and trafficking of
activated t cells to the tumor side with
infiltration into the tumor and finally
the recognition and killing of cancer
cells associated with the release of
antigens that further drives the
progression of this cycle
so each of these seven steps is tied by
regulators involving a multitude of
checkpoint molecules other cells have
this receptors but also soluble factors
such as cytokines and chemokines and for
many and almost all of these factors we
we provide multiplex uh panels such as
for pro and anti-inflammatory cytokines
that regulate the step two we provide a
complete portfolio of chemokines and
adhesion molecules that regulate the
t-cell trafficking and infiltration and
finally our immune oncology checkpoint
biomarker panels particularly focus on
steps three and seven
t-cell activation and and killing of the
cancer cells including most important
co-stimulatory and co-inhibitory
molecules that are often engaged by
cancer cells to alter these activation
pathways and are also targeted by immune
checkpoint inhibitors
in addition to uh this important role of
the adaptive immunity similar processes
and checkpoints can also be found during
inner immune cell activation as depicted
uh by the figure on the on the right uh
showing a lot of receptor ligand
interactions of natural killer cells
that are also to be explored as
potential therapeutic targets that might
mediate anti-cancer immune responses
and the figure furthermore points out
that the immune checkpoint molecules are
primarily considered as receptor ligand
pairs
but a lot of soluble isoforms and shed
variants are described for the majority
of these targets that can function as
immune adjuvants or decoy receptors
thereby regulating the checkpoint
pathways but which might also impact the
clinical efficacy of individual
checkpoint modulator drugs
so um as a consequence the immune
oncology checkpoint biomarker broke
heart diplox panels have been
specifically designed and optimized for
measurement of key immune oncology
analytes in human or mars serum plasma
and cell culture supernatant samples
and this is illustrated by the this bar
chart so and is a screen of more than 70
human melanoma samples finally confirmed
that all these soluble forms of
checkpoint molecules that are included
in the immune oncology checkpoint panel
1 and 2 which each include 14 targets
are indeed detectable in serum
further evaluation of the prokartoplex
immune oncology checkpoint panel 1
showed that the expression patterns of
the soluble markers are dependent on
disease state and cancer treatment so as
demonstrated by the two graphs reduced
levels of pd-1 were detected in melanoma
samples comparing early treatment to
pre-treatment
showing a characteristic responder
profiles which might help to pre-select
and stratify subjects who may benefit
from a certain treatment
and further highlights that analyzing
these soluble checkpoint molecules
will provide the valuable information
for early evaluation of treatment
responses
moreover levels of soluble checkbook
markers could also be determined in
human breast cancer samples as shown
here before and after chemotherapy using
the immune oncology checkpoint panels as
previously published and there is
evidence that the chemotherapy-induced
tumor cell that is related with the
release of intracellular molecules such
as the cell death marker hmgb1 into the
micro environment
so as demonstrated by the box plots
soluble cd27 soluble cd80 and soluble
pdl2 correlated with hmgp bond levels
and were increased in human samples with
every better response to chemotherapy
and the better five-year survival and
this findings such as that the immune
status differs between donors with
increased hmgb1 levels in response to
chemotherapy as compared to donors
without increase
and further underlines the relevance of
immune checkpoint marker analysis to
better adept treatment strategies and
responses
so apart from the human pre-configured
panels mouse the mouse pro carter plex
immuno oncology checkpoint panel one and
two allows analysis of specific soluble
receptors and ligands to support studies
on the response to potential therapeutic
treatment in mouse models and have been
evaluated by a collaborator here in
tissues from mice
so as demonstrated in the two bar charts
uh in total
analysis of 11 analytes in tumor tissue
extracts from treated and
non-treated mice revealed a distinct
protein profile with differentially
expressed proteins in the treated as
compared to the control group suggesting
a role for these proteins in tumor
progression
so in addition to the immune oncology
checkpoint biomarker panels it is also
of great interest to analyze a broader
set of immunoregulatory soluble factors
that provide the significant insights
and then more comprehensive uh profile
uh and picture of an individual's immune
status such as the human immune
monitoring brocardiplex panel that is
actually our largest available panel on
this multiplex platform and enables
efficient analysis of immune response
profile biomarker discovery and
verification by combining 65 cytokine
chemokine and growth factor targets in a
single well
data analysis is furthermore enhanced
those supine intuitive easy-to-use
software solution
with the new procartaplex analysis app
that features 4pl and 5pl curve feed
optimization provides also grouped by
statistical and heat map analysis as
well as export of detailed uh reports
including publication quality images
so in in a recent study uh as cited here
uh both the brocardo plex immune
oncology checkpoint panel and the human
cytokine chemokin and growth factor 45
plex pro cardiflex panel were used to
measure baseline levels of in total 59
soluble immunological factors
before treatment with a pd-1 inhibitor
in plasma samples of a discovery cohort
to finally evaluate the response to
immunotherapy
so based on a calculated signature score
as displayed by the heat map
the correlation between the distribution
that pattern of these soluble factors
and the clinical benefit was
retrospectively
explored in different subgroups
and as depicted uh by the scatterplots
below
significantly distinct pattern was
identified for these three targets so
while a decreasing trend of therapeutic
response was observed for il-10 across
the subgroups significantly increased
pre-treatment levels were identified for
ccl5 forensics and soluble pdl-1
and their relevance as biomarkers for
efficient immunotherapy was further
confirmed in a validation cohort as
depicted in the catapults below
and here moreover the combination of
these two um
target analytes as so-called
two-side-to-kind signature was found to
be associated with increased disease
control rate and survival
which further underscores the predictive
value which is important for the
stratification of individuals who may
benefit from a certain treatment
so finally we continued to expand our
portfolio of multiplex brocardoplex
panel in the cancer research space to
ultimately enables the systematic
analysis of all relevant targets
addressing all hallmarks of cancer and
uncovered the complexity as summarized
by this rationale and originally
published by hanahan and weinberg
and besides the readily available
multiplex panels for growth factors for
angiogenesis related targets and the
three immune oncology checkpoint marker
panels as just mentioned that cover all
relevant soluble t-cell and natural
killer cell checkpoint molecules that
are involved in evading immune
destruction and tumor-promoting
inflammation and that are now also
combined uh in one immune oncology
checkpoint marker panel that encompasses
all these targets and will be available
soon we we further added uh targets of
interest uh focusing on the hallmark of
cancer resisting cell death where we
already uh provide an apoptotic cell
clearance panel and put the particular
emphasis on not yet covered hallmarks
which are actually uh cell proliferation
and also metastasis and invasion that
are among the most fundamental features
of cancer cells
that enables sustained proliferation and
invasive growth capabilities and are in
in the focus of of research so now we
provide three novel multiplex panels
with more than uh 30 highly relevant
targets um
that are underway and coming soon to
allow in-depth analysis of these aspects
as well
finally i'd like to point out and
mention the important role of exosomes
as key mediators of intercellular
communication particularly in this
context that has gained considerable
interest over the past years so exosomes
and their cargo derived from a tumor but
also the tumor micro environment are
increasingly acknowledged as valuable
source of biomarkers and are associated
with essentially all of the described
hallmarks of cancer and many of the of
the related targets that have been
summarized on the previous slide
so basically to characterize this subset
of for small vesicles we have designed
and provide a multiplex brocardoplex
panel including six selected targets as
listed in the table
covering all relevant categories of
proteins to demonstrate the nature and
purity of exosome preparations and
extracellular vesicle preparations in
line with the recommendations of the
international society for extracellular
vesicles that is summarized uh below
so these include actually a typical
tetraspanins as well as an additional
integrin
as transmembrane proteins
synthenin1 representative for cytosolic
proteins and cytochrome c as a control
this unique multiplexer tool for exosome
characterization will also be soon
available
and will provide an even more complete
profile then of cancer immunity and to
leverage your uh immune oncology
research
with that i will end this presentation i
i hope i have given you some insights
into a powerful essays for targeted
approaches but also comprehensive
analysis of immune profiles to support
immune oncology research on the luminex
system thank you for your interest in
participation in this webinar